Cuphead
People are loving cuphead
It's got ten out of ten on Steam thousands of user reviews you guys seem to love it as well, and I criticized
uuuuuhhhhhhh
Game Journalists for being
Bad at the game now that the game has been out a couple of days. Let's see
What major gaming media outlets are saying about cuphead I find cup heads difficulty?
infuriating not fun
Okay that was kataka what about polygons, please don't let cup head speedruns. Make you feel bad about yourself
Don't feel bad about being bad at games
Just don't feel bad. Please can we have a moment of silence for all the bad gamers?
Can we please. I find it really interesting how there's such a
difference between
Gamer and a game journalist with movie reviews I tend to listen to critics
More because they're professional. It's their job. They know how to analyze
movies
Differently than your typical eye, but with games it just seems like the complete opposite
I listen to what the audience review is rather than the critic review because when you're this bad at games
Why should I listen to what you have to say about the game is hard yes, but it's not impossible
cuphead really sparked the debate on difficulty in games and
It even came out an article saying can we have our skip boss fight bottom now Game Journalists?
wants to have a skip boss fight button
But they really laid the foundation of this article very nicely
I would say those who spread toxicity are those most likely to be on the side of condemning
Gaming options that remove challenge so anyone that wants a gaming challenge
You're spreading toxicity. Okay. You need to tone it down a bit
Because you're being quite toxic right now. Can you imagine how annoying it must be that have a challenging bossfight?
And then there's just this skip boss button dangling right next to your face like are you sure oh?
Jeez, this boss is a little difficult. Are you sure you don't want to skip this one buddy look come on click me
That's got to be the worst idea. I've ever heard the journalist also tweeted anyone who ever uses the word
gameplay needs to seriously consider their life choices
What the heck is wrong with gameplay?
Hasn't PC gamer banned the word from its article. I should bloody hope so
What did I miss here what happened what happened I?
Don't want to say. I just don't understand. I did a little bit of digging to understand
Why gameplay is a trigger word apparently for a game journalist and apparently it's because it minimizes video games as an art form
Telling developers how they should make games minimizes games as an art form
Ok cuphead knows what he wants to be and it sticks with it. It's not made for a wide audience
And he doesn't have to be and the people that do love it. Love it, and that's why it's getting so much praise
Lastly no one cares like if I had a friend. That was bad at a video game
I wouldn't actually care all these means about like get good or no casuals
It's a joke like how hurt can you be from it? Please? Don't let cut pic speedruns make you feel bad
I
Probably taught way too much, and I honestly just want to play the game
So I'm just gonna do that okay a lot of you guys pointed out. I didn't actually
equip my goddamn extra heart point
I'm thinking I'm gonna go with the automatic carry though
So you haven't equipped any of it. It's so stupid. See you know even even a pro gamer like myself will make mistakes oh
Cool, I'm in a plane
Weight shrink oh, it's like okay
Hey cool
Whoa so cool. Oh, it's a visit a boss. Oh
Shoes she literally killed me with a laugh attack
That's a meanie right there
She became a cow everybody or a bull
Okay well clearly I've already failed. There's no way yeah. There you go
Wow good job Felix let me change extra hit points. It would probably do me better here. Yes own everybody Oh
Oh
Why am I so bad what the heck man
Stop oh
No oh no, I'm gonna be here a while Oh, No so apparently this game was made literally just by three people
How crazy is that?
gosh damn, man
Apparently also they had to take out a more second mortgage on their house just to be able to afford funding the game
Now tonight's it's pretty cool. It shows the passion of wanting to make something. What is happening it might a bomb. That's a little offensive
Okay, now you went too far cut head
I'm so bad at this boss. I don't blow. That's so cool. What is happening?
Okay this
I
Made it halfway that time. Thanks mom I
Mean trihard mo now it happened finally
I'm doing amazing though. This is it mom. I don't wanna dodge that I did it
Shoes
Love the music - it's the kind of thing I would snap my fingers - if you know what I mean
Oh
What what it mean stop
I'm a bomb I hit the wrong thing alright. We're getting there. Oh
Close one, what is she doing? What is she doing? What is she doing? What is happening? Oh?
Whoa what the heck er that's so cool
Why would you want to skip a boss?
This is so dope Oh
Shoes, I almost got it. Okay. I'll get it this time so it's random which one they turn into oh
I don't know how to dice this
Okay, just go around
oh
I love it
SoDo if we get into Perry I'm not gonna get super now goddamn it
No come on one more life come on yes nice
Listen all right, whatever
Okay, all right don't look don't look hey
A+, A, A, A
Shut up no no no it said a-plus everyone knows it it's yes, I wonder
What's inside his cup you know?
Milk it drinks milk in a cup. I don't mr.. Perry
Well I miss these levels these are fun
What's parry? How do I parry?
Stop no yeah
Leave me alone whoa whoa whoa it's mr.. Pecker. I've missed the parry gosh somebody
What the hell it's a hole
Okay all right here we go no
Come back. I want the coins. Here we go. What's the hacker man? What the woodpecker?
Give up Nikki bug you Oh
Where's my double jump huh what it put in there stop stop it ah
This this Hill sucks, okay, let's oh?
My god this game sucks. Okey?
Slap that stupid thing
Great
Hidden coin got it no way. Oh, my god. What the heck this game is impossible
Don't feel bad Felix. Just don't feel bad about being bad. There's nothing worse about than feeling bad. Oh
There it I'm parring left and right buddy left and right look at that buddy look at that buddy get him
cuphead style
Gangnam style uh, no i was gonna parry that, shoot another one let me parry man
In the world
Cup hits down
Another coin thank you. Oh you made me waste it. I don't trust you. I don't trust you
Oh no someone killed him
Okay here we go
Here we go look at that platforming skills look at this look at the skills look. Oh my god
No the ball of flame just came out of nowhere. Oh my God
No, I must be extremely bad at this game. (you are pewds)
I really don't back up my claims with the gameplay. Do I oh?
My God look at that dude look at that. How do I get up there?
Noo! it! Aah!
I'm fine. I'm fine
What is happening? What is happening? Oh?
my god
You're killing all my friends. I will have to stop you
with my kamehameha, I was not ready for a boss battle. I just
That's gonna hit me
is it dead please be dead
Thank the lord, thank you little flies
Impossible jump. Oh my brother. Let me see my breasts bellissima a grassy male heir tutti Oh
Give me that answer power can
See those skills game journalist
You're never gonna get C+
Showed you I showed you
Long range with below okay, no smoke bomb yeah, I want that one
Invisible - that's pretty good. Oh
That's disgusting you're disgusting he's not which way we're gonna go huh? I'm gonna go up or down that Oh shzzle. Oh
Wait they explode oh shizzle
I just got bamboozled man
What is happening oh
My god. What is he doing? Is he stuck? Oh my god? What is happening?
What's he doing okay, this is different. Oh, wow, okay?
Fine
Shoes
Nope oh
This is a tight one. It's a real tight one boys shoes
Yes got it
That's oh my god
This is why flowers shouldn't have teeth right there a walk in the park first try first. Try are you paying attention?
journalist first try
So easy my God look at that a-plus. I love this game. It's so fun
skip boss option my god
Well look at this new area oh
Why you so sad?
Ok let's go help the mouse I
Am literally stuck this game is absolutely awful
This is the worst game. I have ever say
I'm stuck
0 out of 10
Worst game I take every praise back I take a back out Gemma. There's a glitch in it
Where's the skip boss vital button? Why can't I just skip the entire game? Huh? Where's that option?
Huh you can fast-forward a movie right huh you can fast-forward of the movie. Why can't I just fast-forward with a game, huh?
Huh that's legit criticism. They used oh cool
What I don't I?
Did it what how do I dodged? Oh? I don't know what I'm doing I do I shoot the duck sir. I am pissed
It'll taken out god. I
Don't know what to do let's jump up on the beetle
What the heck just happened Oh
What?
Seriously where's the skip button I don't want this
Come on dude this sucks this sucks this
One is really not that hard at all
Yes, that's right stupid Pluto
What now what now oh my
God, I don't know what's happening all I know is I could die any second. That's a bit creepy oh
wow, okay
All right
Very fast train okay, and I'm dead
God damn this one is difficult compared to the other ones zero deaths, okay zero deaths I
Got it. Now. I get it. I get it. I got it again. I mastered it. I mastered the arts
I mastered the urge all of them all of them at the same time look at that
I missed that move on purpose, and then why it's too easy too easy
Take this stupid bit I hate it. I hate the Super balloons. Okay, they're annoying they're knowing to me. I'm sorry
I hate I don't like vanilla ice very much. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry
I don't like balloons. I'm sorry
I'm killing it though. I'm killing I'm not sorry
die please
No
No, thank you
Oh, we got this stupid one. Yeah, I'm calling you stupid now. Oh
He's gonna come here now. I know you know young your whip is snappy
Get it get it right up your ass, that's right, easy
Must be a genius to figure that out you must be a genius like myself
Come on little penguins
Blah I
missed
Come up penguins where's your little penguins? What are your little penguins? Huh? Where are they time?
Right I killed penguins. What are you gonna?
Do put it by murder of penguins polygon you gonna write about thing you're gonna write about my no. I'm not gonna okay?
Maybe you will write about that thing that can't fight our
Dude last one hit me that was not fair
stop
No, no, I'm not Berenice very easy. Oh my god
It was so easy look how much help I have less 500 it
Look okay alright fine fine. I'm sure you got eight plus the first time you beat
It sure buddy sure buddy sure sure keep talking keep talking know what I hear this
Yeah, but that bad bad bad bet a bad bet I okay alright. That's it for me for it for now
Hope you enjoyed this episode
Leave a like if you did really appreciated. I love cuphead. You know it's not a game for everyone
But there are games for everyone, so play those instead you crybabies
Jitsu ow